Western civilization once prided itself
on its tolerance and its openness that
turned out to be a golden age now we
suffer under the plague of what they're
calling canceled culture the Des Moines
Register reminded all of us last week of
how awful it is when they decided to
crush a charity fundraiser for 27 year
old so for 7 year old tweets now Rubin
report host Dave Rubin is being targeted
for cancellation as well Rubin is
scheduled to appear this weekend at
Mohawk College but in Tifa activists are
trying to stop that event entirely new
joins us right so Dave on what how can
an Tifa which is committed to violent
revolution is not a make should not
never be considered a mainstream group
how are they in charge of whether you
get to speak in public or not yeah well
first off let's just clean up what an
Tifa is you know they call themselves
antifoam meaning that they're
anti-fascist but they are the fascists
these are people yes they are use
violence to silence their political
opponents that's right they have bought
into collectivism they have bought into
identity politics they have bought into
the very idea that if someone holds
different political beliefs than you and
I'm not talking about extreme political
beliefs I'm talking about just any
different political belief than they
have that these people should be shouted
down they should be violently harassed
then silenced so I am scheduled to speak
on the 29th of this month at Mohawk
College in Canada with Maxine Bernier
who is running under the People's Party
of Canada ticket for a prime minister
he's basically a libertarian I've had
him on my show he's a very he is a very
decent man by all accounts he has some
positions you're not gonna believe this
Tucker these are positions of the right
that's what he has as a libertarian and
for these people they have threatened to
shut down the event and they're they
want to take pictures of people that
show up and check their car
you know the license-plate numbers and
all of these intimidation tactics which
they we know they've done at college
events and all sorts of other things we
were informed that they were going to
cause the event to do ten times the
security fee that was originally agreed
upon I
offered to cover that myself I intend on
being there we intend on going ahead
with the event and more than anything
else I mean the sick and twisted part of
this as they call us neo-nazis and the
rest of this I I grew up with Holocaust
survivors in my family in my extended
family and friends and I know what that
is I you know every week I come on your
show and we talk about freedom of speech
we talk about the defense of Western
liberal values and we are we are running
thin on them because they are calling
everyone and not seeing a bigot and it
is silencing good people and we're
running out of runway before they
silenced so many of us that the few of
us that stand up for it we're gonna run
out of room too so we need the good
people that watch your show that watch
my show the good people that is that is
the 90% of Americans and the 90% of West
yes Western living citizens start
standing up because if you live in the
West now if you live in America or
Canada now in 2019 and you're afraid of
saying whether you what you think now
what do you think is going to be like
when these people get into power that's
that's exactly right where we be in 20
years know if we'll be here at all Dave
Rubin
Godspeed we are with you obviously we
thank sucker you've been a huge ally in
this and I appreciate it